all right well national parks are
expected to be very busy this year and
if you plan to visit the great outdoors
there are some things to keep in mind
joining us with some helpful tips is
alex schnee also known as alex on the
map alex how are you
hi thanks for having me on i'm doing
great how are you great yes we're so
excited to chat with you you have a lot
of helpful tips so let's jump right into
it national parks are a hot commodity
this year everyone wants to go and visit
so what are some things that we should
keep in mind if we're planning a trip
out to one of the parks
absolutely well you completely nailed it
um this has been so far a record year
last year was a record year for national
parks so bring your patients would be
the number one thing i would say is
keeping in mind that these crowds are
not likely to go away people have
rediscovered the outdoors um so we need
to all enjoy that together if we can
that would be great um also keeping in
mind that several of the national parks
do have reservation systems this year
partially in order to curb those crowds
so knowing about those before you go can
make your trip a lot more enjoyable
and you know we're out here in las vegas
it's very hot so my first thought is
always weather so with some of these
parks i know it's a little cooler out
there but is weather something to keep
in mind and should you kind of think
about time of day as far as when you're
going to head out on those trails
yes absolutely you know you are right
near those utah national parks which
have been experiencing some flash
flooding recently um canyonlands had a
flash flood a few days ago um there's
been a recent warning for flash flooding
in arches and those other parks so
keeping that in mind for hikers who are
heading out
double check the website just to make
sure that you are safe and ready to go
and also hydrate remember to bring those
water bottles those reusable water
bottles are going to be really helpful
on your time out there
and for less experienced hikers like
myself do you recommend maybe getting a
tour guide or someone to kind of help
make sure you're staying safe out there
absolutely i think that is definitely an
underrated tip that people don't realize
as well is the parts that do require
reservations arches or zion you do not
need reservations if you book a tour so
that is a great way to get around those
systems too is by going ahead and
booking with a local tour agency so that
way you not only get expert opinions
while you're out there but at the same
time you also don't have to worry about
getting your ticket which is probably
already booked up by now unfortunately
so well alex thank you so much for all
the tips i'm gonna tell everyone find
your own social media alex on the map
because you have a lot of great tips on
there so thank you so much for breaking
it all down for us
thank you kendall i'll send it over to
you